Now you may have heard of other
types of orders besides just buy and
sell, market and limit.
It turns out though that the exchanges
only execute these types of orders.
They don't execute those other types.
Well, you might wonder,
okay, how do those other types
of orders come into being?
These other types of orders
are implemented by your broker.
The way that works is you
enter this order type and
I'll give you a couple
examples in just a second.
The broker holds that order and watches
the market until the conditions that you
specified are met and
then when those conditions are met,
the broker sends your order
to the market accordingly.
So here's some examples.
Stop loss is a kind of order
where you say when the stock
drops to a certain price,
I want you to sell it.
Stop gain.
Similarly, when the stock
reaches a certain higher price,
I want you to sell it.
Trailing stop is a combination
of stop loss but
also an automatically changing value for
when that criteria is met.
So for instance, you might have
this trailing stop remain say,
$0.10 behind the price.
So as the price goes up, the value at
which you would want to sell the stock
goes up along with the price,
but when it drops down below.
Then that stop loss is triggered.
But probably the most important and
most impactful kind of order
the brokers implement for
you is something called selling short.
What selling short allows you to do is
take a negative position on a stock,
in other words,
you sell a stock short if you believe
its price is going to go down.
Keep in mind here we're selling
stock we don't even own.
So how is that possible?
Well, again, it's possible because
the broker facilitates it for you, and
I'll explain how in just a minute.